president trump is absolutely right the
deep state's abuse of power it is very
real and under joe biden it is now going
unchecked and now we find out the fbi
has acquired the single most
sophisticated spying tools ever designed
by man now we're going to break this
down for you uh not one but two alarming
new spying scandals it'll make you think
twice about how you use your very own
cell phone and later a supposedly
non-partisan biden nominee accused
senator ron johnson of white supremacy
called them a white nationalist
sympathizer from behind the comfort of
her keyboard on twitter well today the
senator confronted her face-to-face
how would you feel somebody just
privately
called you racist
first of all i would say they're wrong
second of all i would disagree with them
and
as i said earlier but i want to
reiterate that even in my critiques of
people
um i'm very careful
um never to ascribe to the person i
thought you know i heard that i thought
that was interesting you see never
criticized the person
um
but that's not true
what you just what you what you just
testified there is false
i'll use a different word we call it a
lie where i grew up he'll play the full
exchange coming up and senator ron
johnson will be here with reaction but
first we now turn our attention to a
chilling story surrounding an israeli
technology firm now this firm is named
nso group and it's powerful spyware tool
called pegasus now according to reports
pegasus might be the single most
powerful and controversial spyware ever
developed now
once it has access to your phone pegasus
can allegedly copy your messages and
your photos track your location record
your conversations through the
microphone even when you're not using
your phone and get this it can even
film you secretly through your own
phone's camera that's how sophisticated
this is the new york times recently
detailed the intensifying scrutiny over
the technology after evidence that quote
authoritarian governments are using nso
products to spy on political opponents
but according to abc
this technology is frequently used
abroad to hack journalists and
dissidents and human rights activists
and here's what's happening in israel
right now the israeli government is now
investigating this is a huge controversy
in israel claims that the spyware was
being used by the police against
specific israeli citizens
specifically key witnesses in the
corruption trial
of former prime minister benjamin
netanyahu
look at your screen some are even
claiming that multiple witnesses were
actually because of the spying are being
blackmailed into testifying against
former prime minister netanyahu because
of data harvested from their phones
using this spyware oh see all this
information we have say what we want in
court and guess what it will never see
the light of day that is a massive
scandal unfolding in israel and here's
my prediction buckle up
it's not a matter of if but it's a
matter of when spying scandals just like
this will emerge in this country now
here's where the story hits close to
home even though the nso group has been
blacklisted by the u.s commerce
department
can you guess who might have purchased a
license to use this in 2019
yep chris ray's fbi in a statement the
bureau claims that it paid five million
dollars for a limited license from the
nso group for product testing and
evaluation only then the fbi reportedly
renewed the contract for another four
million dollars cyber security experts
are now sounding the alarm about what
they are calling a troubling and
irresponsible move from the highest
levels of the federal government the
same fbi leadership that never held
their own top brass to this day
accountable for the biggest corruption
abuse of power scandal ever when they
use that dirty russian disinformation
dossier that hillary clinton bought and
paid for to spy on donald trump the
candidate the transition team of donald
trump and president donald trump
uh now the only difference is they won't
need to lie to the fisa court to spy
this is extremely chilling especially
because director ray never held these
people accountable never cleaned up his
bureau of the one percent i have my fbi
pin still right there representing the
99 percent of good people that will risk
their lives and obey the laws and not
abuse power and meanwhile another spying
scandal is brewing on capitol hill look
at this breaking today the inspector
general for the capitol police opened a
formal investigation into serious claims
that republican members of congress are
being unlawfully and were unlawfully
surveyed surveilled by capitol police
potentially at the direction of nancy
pelosi look at this from politico hardly
a right-wing publication quote the
capital's intelligence unit quietly
started scrutinizing the backgrounds of
people who met with lawmakers
even republican staffers were allegedly
targeted with surveillance and that's
not all according to one gop congressman
from texas during recess in november
2021 three capitol police officers
entered his congressional office without
his knowledge dressed like construction
workers and began taking pictures of a
white board before being confronted by a
staffer who is still in the office the
police then interrogated the staffer
about the contents on the white board
which detailed various legislative plans
that are under consideration today on
twitter the congressman stated that
perhaps his office was targeted because
quote well i've been a vocal critic of
speaker pelosi the january 6 committee
and the capitol police leadership over
their handling of january 6th and the
death of ashley babbitt and the
subsequent sham investigation so what's
really going on here hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else